this episode of the minimalist is
brought to you by nobody
because advertisements suck and
minimalists hello simpletons welcome to
the minimalist podcast where we discuss
what it means to live a meaningful life
with less my name is Joshua fields
Milburn and I'm Ryan Nicodemus and
together we are the minimalists max luka
Vera's here yeah man max thank you for
joining us thanks for having me so today
we're gonna talk about creating a
healthy lifestyle you're the author of a
few books here I first came in contact
with your work because one of our
favorite restaurants is called El Campo
oh cool yeah and I I saw your book there
genius foods and now you have a follow
up I'll hold this up for the folks
watching on YouTube it is called the
genius life and so I want to dive into
that in fact I think we'll call this
episode today the genius life and I'm
gonna talk about this is a more
comprehensive guide than your first book
and I want to dive into the two the two
books but today we're gonna talk about
just lifestyle we'll talk about managing
stress we could talk about your mind and
strengthening your body and becoming
extraordinary which is the subtitle of
the book here and I found it fascinating
that we can't agree on health and for a
long time that sort of puzzled me last
week we had rich role in the podcast I'm
sure you're familiar with rich
we've friends with Paul Saladino I know
you've had conversations with him before
in fact we had rich and Paul on the same
episode one debate well we tried to
avoid debate and we we tried to figure
out what do they agree on so folks
listen to this Paul is a carnivore
meaning he eats only meat and rich eats
nothing but plants and so there's
seemingly no overlap but surprisingly
they agree on a lot like don't eat a
whole bunch of processed foods and so I
kinda want to get into that and what I
like about your approach is you seem to
you know sort of mesh the best parts of
both of them and and so I want to talk
about that today now today this is a
listener driven show so I thought maybe
we would start with some questions from
our audience let's start with Gavin in
Gilbert Arizona
I'm currently working at a job I love
what I'm getting but I would really like
some some helpful tips on how to blow
off some steam
my boss definitely handles the steam a
lot better than I do he takes on a lot
more work than I do and in a different
kind of aspect
but as someone that manages and creates
every project that comes my way I really
would like to know how to blow off some
steam in those situations where you
don't really work out I got other people
that I work with that don't really help
me out in a way that I wish they did any
other kinds of a little thing and that
could that can be with worth or because
you this person on let me know what you
guys have to offer the voice so max
Gavin here is really talking about
stress right it's not about blowing off
steam how does he alleviate stress now
in your book do you talk anything about
you dealing with stress but also maybe
good stress versus bad stress can we
talk about those as well yeah absolutely
and I you know I could certainly relate
to that I went through the most
stressful time of my life just actually
while I was writing this book the genius
life my mom
Labor Day 2018 was diagnosed with
pancreatic cancer and she passed away
over that over a three-month period in
which I was supposed to be finishing up
the book and you know for anybody who's
ever had a sick sick loved one it's the
worst thing to experience I mean the
world just basically just stops but if I
didn't allocate even don't during the
worst moments with my mom where I wanted
to spend every second with her you know
every second that I had left I carved
out time in my day to get to the gym and
to practice self-care because without
doing that without prioritizing my own
mental health in those moments I
wouldn't made it through to the other
side I certainly would've been able to
finish the book but just my own
fortitude as a human being I was reliant
on on physical exercise and you know
doing things like sitting in a sauna and
the reason that that all of these
modalities help is that they help
strengthen our our mental resilience
there's a concept that I discovered in
the medical literature that I bring
forth in the genius life called cross
adaptation and I think cross adaptation
is really important because when it
comes to stress there are two ways that
we can really deal with the stress in
our lives right one is to reduce stress
but sometimes there are moments where we
can't actually reduce stress right like
there was no way that I was able to
change my situation with my mom and just
like your caller you know sometimes
people have stressful jobs and and I
don't want to sound
this privileged out-of-touch guy
sometimes people have financial burdens
they're in stressful relationships so
the other way that I think people should
really be aware of how to better manage
stress in their in their lives is to
boost their resilience to it so that's
one of that you can either reduce stress
or you could you know accept that you
have a stressful situation Oh stress 'fl
circumstance and then boost your
resilience to it so this notion of cross
adaptation I think is really empowering
and what it basically suggests is that
by engaging in activities that are that
are acutely stressful in the physical
sense like high-intensity interval
training for example or sitting in a
sauna which gets your heart rate going
because you know saunas actually act
like a mimetic for mild aerobic exercise
we actually can have what's called a
spillover effect where the resilience
and the acclamation that our bodies
basically we use to cope with these
physical stressors can make us more
resilient psychologically and mentally
this is one of the reasons why exercise
can make us more you know mentally
resilient or they're now showing in
research I believe it's out of the
University of Chicago where saunas can
actually be used as a powerful means of
mitigating symptoms for people with
major depression yeah
also cold plunge with cold ledges are
another or another you know fantastic
example they're doing studies with
cryotherapy showing the exact same thing
there has been a number of case reports
published where people do what's called
like winter swimming or basically cold
water immersion and they see that that
is a powerful stress relief tool and it
and again it makes you more resilient
when you actually have those stressful
encounters in your day to day life
I love I love how you're explaining how
this self-care routine how being healthy
it builds resilience because you know my
answer for Gavin would have been like
man you got to find a way to exercise
get moving
but bye-bye my reason why is because I
would say well Gavin it'll make you feel
better but it's really the resilience
that Gavin will be building up by by
doing some of these things yeah I think
resilience is really key you know to all
this we want to be as robust as we can
be as organisms right we and that
applies I think in terms of what we're
able to what we feed ourselves you know
we want to have a robust response when
we eat something that we're not supposed
to we want to be physically robust
so we want to be mentally robust and I
think that we can sort of will ourselves
to perform these various activities
whether it's whether it's high-intensity
interval training or sitting in a hot
sauna I think that's a great way to sort
of buy a little bit of added insurance
when these unexpected you know stressful
stimuli emerge which you know especially
these days you know in 2020 mm-hmm
there's a lot of stressful events going
on so if we can you know take the time
prioritize our own self-care and all
this I think we'll definitely be able to
get ahead yeah
the healthier we are the better we're
gonna be able to deal with that stress
the other our body our body's going to
be able to deal with it now let's talk
about some of the things that do
stresses out because you mentioned going
into a sauna or this interval training
or whatever a lot of these things
involve intense focus in a way and also
a clearing of the mind well and I find
that to me the sauna which I do
regularly I'm really fortunate enough
that our our condo building has a sauna
there that if you hack it just right you
can get it up to 220 degrees so it's
it's really great but I find that there
is a clearing out of the mind that
happens and right now with all of the
stimuli and we have it's not just our
televisions you know Ronnie Chang has
this great joke and his most recent
special he said every day in America
feels like a contest to see how many
screens we can get between our face and
the wall and and so there's a big-screen
TV on the wall and then you've got the
laptop on your lap and the iPad and the
in the iPhone and the Apple watch and
and talk about stimuli we are constantly
stimulated with interruptions and we
were distracted and I think more than
ever these distractions are really
stressing us out I stole a soul study
that came out this morning a summary of
a study that Americans are at their
50-year low of happiness now I think a
good chunk of that has to do with the
current crises that are going on but I
also think there are other circumstances
have led to these crises where we are
always on you know I remember when Ryan
and I were in the corporate world we got
our first blackberry
and they're like here it's gonna save
you 30 minutes a day yeah the marketing
changed eventually to 2 hours a day but
no it cost me 14 hours a day it felt
like because I was always on it yeah
yeah I mean we have a finite capacity to
deal with stress and there's actually
another cool term that I discovered for
this referenced in the medical
literature and that is allostatic load
so we have you know our bodies seek
balance and that balance in a in medical
terminology is homeostasis right and so
when we're thrust out of homeostasis
when we're engaging in exercise when
we're on a hike when we're out of breath
when we're sitting in a sauna when were
and get when we're confronted with visit
with with mentals and and physical
stress our body has our bodies have to
take a certain number of steps to
basically get back to that that that
homeostasis and the steps of the but the
cumulative number of steps that your
body takes or the the either the sum
total is known as a low stasis and the
problem I think today is that we've just
got there's like too much stress whether
it's from our streams you know the
screens news excessive caffeine
consumption and excessive you know
processed food consumption we're now
suddenly thrust into a state of what's
called allostatic overload and that
basically is burnout so I think it's
important for people to take an
inventory regularly of the of the total
amount of stressors that they have in
their lives and to kind of like be
mindful of that so that your cup doesn't
run over right what you just said the
word excessive right now and so none of
these things are inherently bad limit
some are for sure they they're I mean no
one's gonna argue that the you know
smoking and maybe it gets you in the
hormesis or something but like it's
probably not the best way to do that
right it and so when we look at many of
these stressors it has to do with the
the amount you know the one cup of
coffee isn't bad but if I have coffee
all day every day and you have 14 cups
like I used to back in the corporate
world that's probably not good for my
adrenals or just for my life in general
yeah I think it's important to kind of
you know like intermittent fasting is a
great example of this so a lot of people
were practicing intermittent fasting
today which in general I'm
I'm a fan of I think it's a very it can
be a very useful tool but if you're
doing extended fasts and on top of that
you're drinking lots and lots of black
coffee for example and you're not
dealing with the sources of
psychological stress in your life and
then on top of that you're throwing in
high-intensity workouts and on top of
that you're not dealing with the
relationship that you're in that's gone
sour then all of those tools which you
know independent of one another can be
very useful very beneficial very healthy
you know as you mentioned coffee is very
healthy observational e we look at you
know data we see that people who consume
coffee for example have tend to have
bitter neurological health and then
those who don't but it's always like a
case-by-case basis and if in your life
you're drinking too much of it or you're
drinking it in the context of chronic
stress then suddenly it becomes a
double-edged sword right yeah it's it
these are all tools right you can use a
brick to build a homeless shelter or you
can use it to destroy your neighbors
window right and it's how we use these
tools the brick doesn't care either way
and the same is true with the coffee or
any of these other things that we sort
of use in our life if we use them in
excess or use them inappropriately then
of course we're gonna get bad results
well Gavin I'm gonna send you a copy of
the genius life I think you'll enjoy the
book Sean if you could reach out to him
and and send him a copy I'd appreciate
it
our next question is from Elizabeth in
Los Angeles I deal with chronic daily
migraine and I'm wondering I've worked
really hard a vision past two years to
get in better shape get my migraines in
your control I'm making progress but as
the as we enter the summer season and
the weather gets more extreme I'm trying
to maintain or modulate those habits
like my daily walking daily exercise
dietary habits so that I can maintain
that success and continue to make
progress but I'm noticing an increase in
my migraines and I'm wondering if you
have any advice for dealing with chronic
pain in a way that does not express it
and is moderate and doesn't add
- really chaos that his life so max
Elizabeth here she's taking some small
steps in the right direction and I think
that is advisable for most people she's
suffering with migraines in fact they
are increasing what do you know about
migraines because honestly I know very
little yeah I mean I look I can speak
generally I'm not a medical doctor but I
you know I've died what has become my
passion is to understand how best to
feed the brain and I think that you know
a diet that's good for the brain is
going to be good for you know the
potential prevention of any number of
neurodegenerative conditions and also
even helping to mitigate symptoms of you
know mental issues you know depression
anxiety and possibly even reduce
migraines but I'm not saying that you
know as a clinician so I'm saying that
basically based on just my sort of
understanding of the medical literature
and I will tell you that I do have a
friend who actually is a neurologist and
I'm not gonna name him obviously but he
has suffered for a very long time with
with migraines and I discovered a small
study that found that that were it was a
it's it was suggested that fairly high
dose vitamin D could help people with
migraines and so deficient does a
country yeah yeah I mean most of us are
I believe the statistics are you know
three-quarters of us are deficient in
vitamin D and we could talk all about
vitamin D I go I do it pretty deep dive
in the genius life but it's important
it's it's a hormone in the body that
controls the expression of nearly 5
percent of the genome so a thousand
genes just imagine being deficient in
vitamin D and having you know a thousand
genes in the 23,000 you know gene human
genome basically handicapped by the fact
that you're not getting adequate amounts
of this of this hormone so vitamin D I
think is important you know so I would
look into that but generally just
consuming a diet and living in a way
that minimizes inflammation in the body
mm-hmm let's talk a bit about
inflammation yes when people hear that
word they think of injury I sprained my
ankle and that's inflammation but we
don't think about that low level chronic
inflammation yeah and so maybe you can
you can explain the difference yeah so I
mean a lot of people think that info
is this overall bad thing but it's not
bad at all it's actually a life saving
feature of the immune system that was
there to spot clean cuts wound scrapes
you know protect us if we were exposed
to the occasional pathogen but you know
as opposed to in antiquity when this
this feature if you will of the immune
system was used acutely and locally
today it's being activated systemically
and chronically not as a response to the
occasional insult but to what we're
eating and how we're living yeah and
this is actually one of the major issues
with Kovan 19 so I mean a lot of you
know obviously we've been dealing with
this pandemic for the past couple of
months and what seems to have emerged in
the literature is that people who have
high baseline levels of inflammation
people who are perhaps overweight or
obese or are suffering from type 2
diabetes both of which are characterized
by chronic low-grade inflammation that
there's this inflammatory cytokine storm
which basically increases the risk for
morbidity and mortality but aside from
that it's just not a great state of
affairs for the body to be and because
inflammation is not it's not a free ride
so whenever inflammation wherever
inflammation occurs in the body there's
what's called collateral damage
essentially it's like a shootout in a
public park so I mean the bad guys
usually get swept up in that in that in
that fire but so do things that you
don't necessarily want to get damaged
right so when inflammation occurs
chronically and all over your body it
can I mean it's basically what is now
being thought of as the underlying
characteristic of all if not if many if
not all of the kinds of chronic diseases
that we're now seeing saddling society
and the kinds of conditions which now
kill 60% of people worldwide and a lot
of that can be addressed through food I
learned that through dr. Saladin oh and
yeah and through talks with him and I
mean he is is a rather restrictive diet
if we can call it that you you look at a
more holistic approach it seems like
yeah I mean I you're not allergic to
plants no no I think actually that my
dietary approach is among the more the
most balanced in there like the new
nutritional whatever you want to call it
in the in the nutrition sphere and so
people from both sides hate you yeah
exactly exactly um no I'm uh you know
I'm actually I consider myself to be
carnivore adjacent because I do think
that it's rare to see somebody who takes
a balanced approach and is advocating
for the responsible and ethical
consumption of meat let me pause you
there though because I look at your book
and but I look at the cover of your
other book as well and I look at this
and I say well you are vegan adjacent as
well right well and so what we're really
talking about is some plants are okay
for us at least for most people I have a
bunch of ulcers in my small intestine
you might call it crohn's disease I
don't know that I would put and if I eat
half of a sweet potato
like I feel inflammation in my ankles
for a day and so I have you know I
mitigate that by reducing certain foods
in my life now what you're you you are
advocating is is a healthy lifestyle and
I think it's not only with food but this
inflammation and getting inflammation
under control does start with food yeah
it definitely starts with food I mean
food today you know we live in a world
where sixty percent of the calories that
we're consuming come from
ultra-processed foods and I actually
didn't hear the conversation with
Saladino and rich roll but I would
imagine that where they overlapped is
that they were both issuing
ultra-processed foods which now most
people consume with abandon
so that's just my assumption and that's
honestly the way that every diet book on
the shelves at your local book store is
gonna work I mean there is no diet that
I know of that's advocating for
increased consumption of ultra-processed
foods so with that said I mean whatever
diet it is that you choose to adopt
chances are that diet is going to work
if you adhere to it the approach that I
take is balanced in that it accords both
properly ethically raised animal
products which I think are you know
absolutely healthy like grass fed red
meat you know like shout out to our
friends at Bell camp oh you know I think
that that's absolutely a health food I
don't think I think it's pretty hard to
debate the virtues of grass-fed meat
from a nutritional standpoint and you're
a fan of organ meats as well I saw I am
yeah I'm a fan of organ meats it's it
there's a bit of a learning curve I will
admit that I'm not like you know one of
these carnivores that has like brains
you know in my
frig but but yeah I mean I think organ
meats are there they're nutrient-dense
like liver is one of nature's
multivitamins yeah if you I deliver this
morning oh you did oh that's awesome
yeah yeah yeah I usually yeah yeah I try
to I mean I try to eat it at least once
a week it's such a it's a powerful
source of vitamin b12 and preformed
vitamin A but then I also I'm a big
advocate of consuming plants as well I
think that in a perfect world in a state
of you know you bios's which is
basically you know if all of us had
healthy optimally functioning
microbiomes which we have yet to even
fully define in the medical literature
but we do know that the microbiome is
important the exact role that it plays
in our in our health I think has yet to
really be elucidated but in a world
where everybody has healthy immune
systems there's no autoimmunity we're
all born vaginally there's not
antibiotic overuse we're not obsessed
with these hyper sterile lives and you
know we haven't been using antiseptic
soaps and things like that for decades
I think plants would be beneficial for
for all people but today we live in a
time where there's widespread immune
dysfunction and for the sake of you know
this argument we could define it as
perhaps auto active autoimmunity mmm-hmm
people respond negatively to certain
molecules in different plants yes and so
I think that it makes a lot of sense
that from that standpoint that you know
people that cut out certain certain
plants might see a reprieve of certain
symptoms do I think that it's a it's
smart to make a generalized
recommendation to all people that plants
are bad no I don't think so I think the
bit I think with every treatment whether
it's medicine whenever you're whenever
you're engaging any sort of like
activity there's always you always are
making whether you're cognizant of it or
not a risk-benefit analysis right and so
I think that the benefits of consuming
plants are gonna outweigh the risks for
most people mmm-hmm yeah um Ryan I know
you and I are obviously we're omnivores
max is an omnivore right 97% of people
98 percent of people listening to this
are are probably omnivores and and then
they're I think that works for most
people but I'm the for just like saying
vegan or yeah whatever that doesn't by
definition make
get healthy you could eat you know
Snickers bars all day and be an omnivore
that that means nothing right what we're
really talking about here is cutting out
the processed foods but then also it
sounds like cutting out the triggers
that if you have immune dysfunction and
yeah I would suspect at least is my
hypothesis someone like Elizabeth who
deals with migraines or people well my
father was schizophrenic for example in
other studies coming out showing that a
lot of that has to do with brain
inflammation right and so if we're
talking about reducing inflammation that
definitely starts with food you can just
see this by fasting by the way if
someone who doesn't prolong fast reduces
inflammation well that's not the long
term prescription that's not going to
help you you know indefinite fasting and
so it's about then reintroducing the
foods that aren't going to trigger those
autoimmune issues yeah I also think
certain nutraceuticals might be able to
help you know curcumin has been shown to
possess anti-inflammatory qualities I'm
a huge fan of extra-virgin olive oil
it's basically the primary oil that I
use in my kitchen it's a myth that you
can't cook with it by the way you can
cook with extra virgin olive oil at low
to medium temperatures but extra virgin
olive oil for example it's a it's a it's
a plant food right and it has a compound
in it called olio kanthal which has been
shown in studies to be as
anti-inflammatory as low-dose ibuprofen
but without any of the potential
negative side effects that come with the
chronic use of ibuprofen Wow
so yeah so I mean extra-virgin olive oil
is a great example of an
anti-inflammatory food so instead of
like pop into ibuprofen you would take
like a tablespoon of olive oil like that
could potentially help yeah I actually
do that and it's awesome I'm gonna try
that because I get headaches sometimes
and I'll pop an ibuprofen cuz my stomach
can handle it but I know it's not the
best for me for sure yeah I mean I think
you know there's no such thing as a
biological free free lunch and
especially with these drugs
I don't place any stigma on the use of
pharmaceuticals because if you need them
you need that right and and you should
you know we're I'm glad that they're
there for people that need them but it's
really about the drugs that you use
chronically that I think you want to be
kind of mindful of this so if you're if
you are chronically reaching for the
ibuprofen ask yourself why see if there
are other you know areas of your diet or
lifestyle that you might be able to
tweak that are gonna have a similar you
know anti-inflammatory effect it's so
funny we were
helping some refugees in Missoula
Montana when we were living there and we
were cooking with olive oil and the the
woman who was helping us cook she was
like you cook with olive oil she was
like in my country like it's just it's
for your hair it's for your face like
they don't cook with it at all but yeah
it was it was interesting one thing
about health too it's like there's is no
perfect diet there is no like okay Josh
this is what you need to do and everyone
else needs to do to be 100% healthy take
some work to figure out like what diet
works best for your body like when I
look at rich veganism obviously works
great for without a doubt I hope I look
that good when I turn yeah and you look
at Paul salad 53 you look at Paul salad
you know I think he's like 40-something
isn't he yeah he looks younger than us
so it's like there is no perfect die so
for Elizabeth here I mean she has to
figure out what works best for her now
let me ask you guys like would would it
be appropriate to like recommend for her
an anti-inflammatory diet to try it out
if she hasn't done this yet like an
autoimmune protocol yeah I mean I think
I think it's definitely worth a shot as
sort of a front-line approach to dealing
with this because again you know a
chronic reliance on these pain
medications are not without risk you
know we know that people who chronically
take NSAID drugs these non-steroidal
anti-inflammatory drugs have a pretty
significant increased risk for
cardiovascular events they they've been
shown to actually damage the the
mitochondria of cardiac tissue which are
the the power plants of cells
essentially so yeah I would I would you
know absolutely advocate for trying you
know to make changes to your diet and
lifestyle that and and seeing how that
and seeing how that plays out before
reaching for these for these drugs I
know like as I've gotten older I've had
you see the psoriasis or eczema that
like my I'll get really dry on my face
and I've done the anti-inflammatory diet
and it totally reduces that but like you
said you're always like you know
weighing out the costs so sometimes I'll
have you know there will be something
and I'm like uh I'm okay I'll get a
little psoriasis from this but I'm gonna
go ahead and eat this yeah I mean it's
you it's what is the call and the thing
is if you're willing to pay the cost of
admission there right it's like you
the problem is when the cost is really
delayed like smoking you could smoke a
cigarette right now and it's not going
to hurt you immediately right my mother
died of lung cancer when she was just 64
years old and she smoked since she was
16 and so it takes many many years to
end up paying that cost right that it's
the the opposite delayed gratification
it's the the delayed expense of some of
these decisions I want to move on
Elizabeth I want to send you I shall
send you a copy of genius I think you'll
find some value in that and also since
you're in Los Angeles we've got a tour
coming up in November a podcast tour
we've got a special guest in every city
also a musical guest we do a live
version of the minimalist podcast answer
a bunch of questions have a lot of fun
we're going to a bunch of cities but
we'll send you a couple tickets
Elizabeth and four other folks who are
interested in coming to one of those
tour stops the minimalists comm slash
tour if you don't city see a city near
you you can sign up for the email list
we'll notify you when we're coming to
your closest city Ryan what time is it
you know what time it is it's time for
our lightning round where we answer your
text messages you can text your
questions and comments to nine thirty
seven two zero two four six five four
yes indeed those texts go to both of our
phones literally and we actually do we
reply to some on the podcast we reply to
a bunch of people just from our phones
whenever we have a chance now max during
the lightning round this is where Ryan
and I do our best to answer every
question with just a short shareable
less than 140 character response we put
the text of these minimal Maxim's in the
show notes so people can copy and share
our pit the answers on social media if
they'd like and they can find all of our
minimal Maxim's in one place now minimal
Maxim's com but really we just monitor
on it yeah you don't have to give 100
now it's not really fair because we had
to we got to prepare for this right yeah
you just ramble and then podcast Shawn
will make it look really nice and posted
all right he's a great editor all right
April's question for us Ryan from April
she's writing can you have a discussion
on Joshua's stance that food isn't
entertainment you know what's crazy Josh
yeah this has created I've seen
controversy around that essay he wrote
an essay a long time ago that titled
food is not entertainment
yeah I think it was a line in the essay
but yeah I think it was about minimal
thoughts on food or something like that
yeah yeah yeah it's just it's crazy how
this like I don't know it creates some
visceral reactions from people and that
I know
reven would have guessed would have well
my wife's a dietitian nutritionist a
great cook and and so she worked with
college kids for over a decade and
really understands this but even even
someone like her gets a bit of a
visceral reaction to it because she is
like max very balanced so I used to be
morbidly obese I weigh 280 pounds more
than I weigh now I also had a mullet oh
my god podcast Sean should like fine no
it's I have a picture on my down
secretion find that picture on Instagram
and like put it or I'm sorry George put
that up on YouTube right now just a
little flash yeah I was I was Ryan I
first met in the fifth grade I was the
fattest kid in our school Ryan was the
second fattest so we bonded over
cheeseburgers and cheese fries and
cheese was a lot of processed cheese's
yeah and so so I lost a bunch of weight
in high school really unhealthful II I
just basically didn't eat much and it's
I can't of course gained it all back in
my early 20s because that's what you
when you don't have the habits and you
think that well I'll get vegetables if I
just need enough french fries that's
that's a problem right and so I was
irresponsible and I entertained myself
with food I use it as a pacifier
whenever I got stressed out I would eat
whenever I got upset I would eat and
whenever you got bored you woody
absolutely yeah I found a lot of excuses
to eat right right and also I didn't
understand nutrition I didn't understand
about micronutrients I didn't understand
macronutrients I didn't understand any
of it and and so I gained the weight
back in my 20s and then eventually lost
it by eating more healthfully and
throughout my 20s and then in my 30s and
you know I'm healthy now I have a
pristine diet at this point and I think
people get confused Ryan when I say food
is not entertainment or we shouldn't be
entertained by food what I'm really
saying is that we shouldn't pacify
ourselves right but it doesn't mean that
we can't enjoy our meals and I think
that's a difference so my pit the answer
for you Ryan is don't confuse pleasure
with well-being and I think that's yeah
you can eat a piece of chocolate cake
and it tastes really good during
mastication right there's all this
gluten and sugar and and fat is dancing
on your tastes gonna release that
dopamine it's gonna
make you feel really maybe you know
joyful temporarily well yeah pleasurable
pleasure there will be no there'll be no
real joy in ever absolutely because
that's where we confuse it and in fact
it may actually get pleasure often not
always but and I'm not against pleasure
but it often gets in the way of
well-being when we seek pleasure as the
the sort of outcome yeah yeah I would
have to agree with that actually my
senior thesis film in college was a film
I was a documentary that I made all
about hedonism as a sort of ethical
pursuit you know okay Pro hedonism in
this well as an undergraduate going to
school in Miami yes I was very much pro
okay you got to explain what does
hedonism like I know I know what it is
but I can't I can't think about what
hedonism is it's it's basically pleasure
it's the pursuit of pleasure okay yeah
but the process as the highest virtue as
the highest virtue yeah and and I think
that you can run into problems when you
don't sort of have within your purview
the long-term goal and that you know
part of what it means to feel good is to
be able to feel good and to persist you
know as an entity and to feel good not
just today in the short term but to be
able to like be free of disease and to
feel good tomorrow and the next day and
then and the day after that right
because if all we were was I mean if all
we had you know in our focus was the
short term I mean you could say that
like you know why not smoke cigarettes
then or doing cocaine whenever you want
you know like or any of these things
that we know that are not good for us so
I think you have to we're jumping on the
airplane without a parachute it would be
the determinist example of that right
now because you might experience joy and
like who wants to be encumbered by a
parachute when you can just you know
freeball it so to speak yeah right out
of the plane yeah well of course you
know that ends well I mean that's not
gonna end well now I understand what I
was called a headon at 25 years yeah but
what you're talking about is is I think
hedonistic eating and I think that's a
big problem I think we we tend to do too
much of that and I think it's partly
because of what we were talking about
earlier the fact that we're just
inundated with stress today but food
today has become hyper palatable it's
ultra pleasurable it pushes our brain to
a bliss point beyond which self-control
is futile and I think part
of your what you said I think was right
on is that we've got a we've gotta
basically free ourselves from this this
pattern of hedonic eating and look at
food more as you know as something that
can fuel us and can help us feel better
tomorrow or the next day and to live a
long time to be free of disease and
things like that which are all worthy
yeah yeah I mean yeah it's you know
pleasurable to eat a bunch of Twinkies
but that's if that's where you go for
your entertainment I mean it's it's not
gonna be entertaining for very long
yeah it doesn't enhance your wellbeing
either yeah yeah my pet the answer is
this emotional support is the antidote
for emotional eating and I think that is
really I think that's where people go
wrong food isn't easy it's like a drug
it's a very easy thing to go to to feel
better instantly but there's a deeper
thing going on and if you can you know
hit that deeper issue head-on
you're gonna get through those stressful
times a lot easier a friends support is
gonna be a lot better support than how
food is gonna support you yeah yeah
especially that that the the hedonistic
food right there's ultimately food how
helpful food supports us long-term but
when we feel like binge eating then then
the support of a friend or a community
because they don't they go a long way
yeah yeah yeah I mean I'm guilty of
hedonic eating myself sometimes you know
I'm I definitely you know will buy
comfort foods and things like that I'll
go to like the what I don't know how
what your thoughts aren't cheat days or
whatever but they said you have I could
go to pacifier food yeah I mean look I'm
pretty lucky I live in LA so I have at
my fingertips and you know any number of
ultra-processed foods that are that are
like one step healthier than what you'll
typically you know find or like the
kinds of junk foods that we grew up on
yeah but only Twinkies healthy to it
they have those you can go to a local
health food store and find things like
yeah but yeah like you know generally
I'll eat like if I find like a good keto
chocolate chip cookie or something like
that yeah
I'm not saying that those foods are
health foods they're definitely comfort
foods they can be very calorically dense
you know so that it's so they're not
great for you there's all
so now a line of products that have come
out they're like candies but they're
like made with somewhat healthier
ingredients yeah it's all go through
like a bag of those you know yeah but uh
but yeah I mean I think it's always
smart to kind of be aware of what you're
doing and why you're doing it so at the
very least it's informed consent I think
too often what's the case is that we
tend to reach for these foods and then
you know with the intent of only having
you know one or two pieces or you know
one or two scoops of a pint of ice cream
for example and then we end up at the
bottom of the pint or at the end of the
back story in my life yeah and I talk
about that a lot in my work that you
know these these foods that again
they're they're referred to by food
sciences is hyper palatable because they
create repeat customers you know they're
just impossible to moderate our
consumption of these foods and so a lot
of people what they end up doing when
they over consume them is they feel like
moral failures you know they the it
promotes black or white thinking they
feel like they've fallen off the
bandwagon they feel like they're just
not good at this whole being healthy
thing or this whole dieting thing when
in reality I think these people need to
know that these foods are designed to be
over consumed it's not a moral failing
if you choose to indulge in them at
least let it be informed consent and
make that decision to have a planned
indulgences what I like to call them all
right before we get into our listener
tips and our added value segment today
ironic can't wait to talk to you about
this added value because I think you and
I both got something different out of it
but I think we added value to both of
our lives yeah so I want to talk about
that but first it looks looks like we
got a bunch more surprise questions this
week like how can minimalist practices
help improve my health how can I use
minimalism to address the challenges of
a chronic illness also does poor mental
health affect our performance and what
are some exercises that max would
recommend for someone who does not have
access to gym equipment and does not
want to spend money on excess items Ryan
we're also gonna talk about longevity
we're gonna talk about air quality and
pollution we're gonna talk about
processed foods we're gonna talk about
the immune system all that and a million
more questions for max luga veer and if
you want to hear all that check out our
maximal episode this week on the
minimalist private podcast it's a
completely separate podcast not just a
separate episode it's a separate podcast
feed
and it's just a couple bucks and it's
the most honest way for the minimalists
to earn an income because we don't
believe in advertisements so we make
money only if you find value in and
support what we create head on over to
the minimalists comm slash support to
subscribe and get a personal link so
that our private podcast plays in your
favorite podcast app you can find all
the details over there on our website
the minimalists comm slash support ryan
what else you got for us this week here
are some voicemail comments and tips
from our listeners check them out hi
Josh Ryan my name is Perry I'm calling
in response to Christina from the neo
minimalism podcast one way that I've
found to introduce friction to online
buying is with passwords so I will
either just delete all of the safe
passwords in my computer or phone or I
will change the password on a site and
I'll write it down and put it someplace
where I have to actually go get it if I
want to buy you something from that
website so that way I have to really
want to buy something otherwise I go to
sign-in and I'm just like no way this is
too much work so that's a really easy
way to prevent yourself from impulse
buying hi my name is Theresa and I'm
calling from Indianapolis and I just
found your podcast so I'm going through
Miranda Moyer and this is about podcast
number 92 somebody mentioned they had a
lot of papers and they mentioned medical
I just retired from working in medical
records in an oncology office please
PLEASE obtain and keep your own medical
records scan them into a secure file the
law only requires medical facilities to
keep those for seven years and if a
doctor can't verify your previous
diagnosis and treatment it could affect
your current treatment and treatment
plan so please take care of your medical
records make them available for your
next doctor alright y'all thanks again
to max Luke aveer for joining us today
check out his book the genius life we'll
put a link to this in the show notes
also he has a podcast of the same name
called the genius life if you enjoyed
our conversation with him today you'll
enjoy that you can check out in his
Instagram feed as well we'll put a link
to that in the show notes he does some
work out some food tips a bunch of
comprehensive coverage there on his
Instagram feed check that out in our
show notes as well you know if you like
him on here you'll like his podcast
you'll enjoy the genius life his book as
well Ryan for our added value this week
Dave Chappelle recorded his new special
now this special is like a preview know
so here's the thing
Netflix recorded a special with him and
they decided to now initially it was
reported that it was going to be a
preview on YouTube and then they were
gonna do something on Netflix separate
that was the initial reports but it
appears that Netflix just released this
on YouTube yeah on Netflix is a joke
they have a youtube channel called
Netflix as a joke right Yeah right
and so they've released it on YouTube
Dave Chappelle special it's called 8:46
and that is the time that George Floyd
was held down held down with a knee to
his neck and murdered and you know the
special it was filmed in Dayton Ohio
well Yellow Springs which is a suburb of
Dayton and and you know you and I have
spent a lot of time out there and so he
did the social distancing thing in fact
it was reportedly the first concert to
happen in in North America since the the
pandemic outside of I guess drive-ins
they've done some drive-in concerts
where people hang out in their cars with
their windows up and our windows cracked
maybe now what did you get out of this
the special 8:46 cuz you you had a
visceral reaction to it in a good way
yeah I mean I got out of it just how
unfairly black people are treated by
cops I mean it was perspective from a
black person about how I mean the
craziest thing from that is how spoiler
alert he had a cop pull him over yeah
and he was like all right in Beavercreek
yeah and he's like hey I've got my son
let you know I'm gonna go to my glovebox
I'm gonna get my license of registration
and the cop is like yeah I know who you
are Dave Chappelle mm-hmm and he was
like great and he got let go
but then that same cop that pulled him
over ended up killing someone unarmed
right later like the following week or
something and he made the point of like
why do I gotta be Dave Chappelle to not
get treated like a suspect
yeah and you know unfortunately and I
don't know where this comes from whether
it's systemic racism in our the
authority that's set up whether it's
whatever it is man like there is
something there's some good points that
he makes as far as some discrimination
that happens and yeah I mean is it was a
it was a good take on it and it really
helped me I don't think I can ever truly
understand but helps me you know get
closer to understanding yeah yeah
there's something about you know our
continuous conversation about empathy
versus compassion and while it's gonna
be impossible for you and me to have
complete empathy for that situation even
though I grew up in it and saw my
brother being treated differently by
police than than me
yeah because of the color of his skin
you know what's interesting is that so
drunk got tased twice in high school yes
and it's funny because I can look at
those times and I could say well he was
acting angrily yes yeah absolutely
well you know it's interesting cuz at
the time I looked at I was like well he
was acting angrily and that's you know
that's something that maybe he could
have avoided wouldn't gotten tased but
here's a thing mm-hmm
I'd be freaking angry too if I got
pulled over for the same reasons he got
pulled over right and here's the thing
you've likely I know I have I've acted
angrily toward cops and I've never been
tased 100% and I've acted the same exact
way he's acted and and that's the point
it's not that he well he did something
wrong yes he did but he was treated
different for that that wrongness right
and and what we could have a debate on
whether or not there's systemic racism
or whatever to me these term starts to
lose meaning because people won't have
debates around these things there was
there are instances of racism we all
know the race if I think everyone agrees
on that yes and what Dave Chappelle's
special brought up was whether or not
you believe in systemic racism or you
believe that racism is even a problem in
America writ large you can recognize
that there are instances that people go
through especially black people go
through especially black men go through
that it makes it more difficult to feel
safe in your own sort of neighborhood
and feel safe around the people that
that protects you and he bring
have some really great analogies I won't
I won't go through them here in the
special other than to say check it out
we'll put a link to it in the show notes
it's on YouTube it's called 846 and he
does a great job it's a stand-up special
there so there's some comedy there a
little bit yeah and and but that's the
thing Chappelle has always not focused
on the the laughs per minute even if you
look stick sticks and stones which I
think might be the greatest stand-up
special of all time yeah I think you can
make a case for that even in that
special he's not focusing on how many
laughs can I get in per minute mm-hmm
it's a TED talk with laughter yeah and
that that's especially what happens here
and he is able to report on cultural
things and inject some humor into them
he's a master at it absolutely yeah so
check it out we'll put a link to that
the show's interesting man is again I
used to I used to look at certain
situations like with your brother and be
like oh well you know this isn't racism
this is insert you know white man's
opinion there yeah and what Dave
Chappelle's and I've come so far from
that but Dave Chappelle special if
you're someone who is you know you're a
white person or you're looking at and
you're saying oh this is so blown out of
proportion and oh you know this there's
no racism watch that special and tell me
that there's not racism yeah yeah
without a question there's racism there
are other times though that we can
assign a racial motive to things and we
need to be clear about this as well
where race is not involved and so what I
like about Chappelle is he is able in
this I see this in my brother as well
and you know Jerome damn near as well as
I do
he were we're able to see race without
seeing everything through the lens of
race yes and that's what Chappelle does
masterfully yeah and I appreciate that
because when everything becomes tinted
with race then you see racism and
everything and Chappelle doesn't see
racism and everything my brother Jerome
doesn't see racism and everything but
also recognizes just like you and I
recognize that there that race can play
a factor in certain things like being
tased by the police unnecessarily it can
play a role doesn't mean that it
necessarily it plays a role but it can
play a role real quick Ryan for right
here right now I'm excited to announce
this maybe you could talk more about it
but we have
we have a new e-book yeah it's free yes
and because budgeting is free and and
and so I think you and you've done a lot
of mentoring over the years you know
over a thousand hours of mentoring
people at this point now I started in
the corporate world because you were a
phenomenal mentor in the corporate world
Oh keep going and and then we started
the minimalist I I started this writing
class and you started mentoring people
one on one at one point that became too
much to handle because the man was six
eight nine months out at some point
right because you didn't want to take on
20 clients at once or anything you have
more clients and there was time right
and so one of the main things that came
up in addition to minimalism and stuff
was budgeting yeah I mean a common
factor that comes up a lot is money
people have money problems whether it's
budgeting whether it's trying to pay off
debt whether it's trying to retire I
mean people have money problems and I
don't want to undermine money problems
they are problems yes so the key to
getting control of your financial life
it is with budgeting and that's why
we're doing this ebook the financial
freedom cuz it is it is really a
budgeting book it tells you how to
create a budget and yeah if you're
someone who is struggling with money
this is a great perspective I would
totally recommend you check out and if
free is in your budget right you can
check it out the minimalists com a slash
budget we'll put a link to this in the
show notes as well it just came out if
you're on our email list you you already
know about it but financial freedom the
free budgeting ebook we put it together
it's five difficult steps to you know
get your budget under under wraps
basically right and so you want to talk
anymore about it you just want to have
them check out the the blog post yeah
check out the blog posts I mean it's a
again it's just a perspective that I
think would add value to anyone who is
struggling with budgeting and struggling
with money and by the way that doesn't
mean it I found that rich or poor I mean
it's like this matter who you are when
we grew up poor we you and I would have
really benefited from a budget and I
know one of the the key excuses that
people use with you when they were your
clients people would often say what I'm
poor I don't need to budget to know that
I'm poor right and it's like well if you
don't know how poor you are like
that's you're doing yourself a
disservice mm-hmm I I do understand that
there's some extreme poverty in this
country in this world and if you you
don't have a budget especially in an
impoverished situation you're you are
only hurting yourself right now it's
funny you know Derek Siver's who sold
his company CD Baby for 22 million
dollars at one point which by the way he
donated all that to charity hundred
percent of it with the chair oh wow
and so he had someone ask him tell me
about what it was like I really want to
know was like to finally become rich
he's like okay it happened when I was 22
I made twenty-two thousand dollars a
year and I spent sixteen thousand
dollars a year and that's the first time
I became rich and they're like no no I'm
talking about like when you you know you
you formed a company and you started
making he's like oh that's those are
just the details like that's the math
the way that I became rich is I started
spending less money than I earned I was
making twenty-two thousand I was
spending 16 thousand thats when I became
rich and by the way that's what enabled
him to donate 22 million dollars he's
not a multi-millionaire as a result of
the sale of that company right a hundred
percent of that money was given away to
charity yeah the reason that he's well
off is because he has his expenses
expenses under control and he does that
through spending less than he makes and
that's what budgeting is really about
now you go through some of the details
in the e-book anyway check it out we'll
put a link to in the show notes the
minimalists com slash budget you can
follow the minimalists on facebook
twitter and instagram at the minimalists
come on come to one of our live podcast
shows you can visit the minimalists com
a slash tour to find a city near you if
you have a question comment or
minimalism tip for our podcast email a
voice memo to podcast at the minimalists
com you can comment on this episode at
youtube.com slash the minimalist and if
you want our show notes in your inbox
sign up for our email list over at the
minimalists com you'll also receive a
simple Sunday email whenever we send
those out no spam no junk no
advertisements ever we just want to add
value to your inbox and if you leave
here today with just one message we hope
it's this
a lot of people and use things because
the opposite never works thanks for
listen y'all we'll see you next time
and minimus